[Music]
I heard about the Pulu earthquake here
in Makassar around the Maghrib praying
time and my wife told guna wons
grandmother directly about what happened
in Poland his grandmother was worried
about his condition and called him all
of the family here tried to call a gong
many times a gong has two mobile phone
numbers and they both couldn't be
reached
[Music]
convicted uh we didn't give up trying to
call him and then called his father his
father is a very calm person and said
that a gong might still be on duty so
that could be why his mobile phone is
off
maybe after he finishes a gun will call
back so we tried to call a gong all
night but couldn't contact him
[Music]
[Laughter]
and at that time I called his mother she
said that a gong had died because he
jumped from the air traffic control
tower she cannot speak anymore she's
only crying loudly his mother never
thought that one of the victims would be
one of our family Antonius gonna wanna
go
you